globally there are about 27 000
universities in the world um you know
most people have only heard of a small
fraction of them but the majority of
people are are going to you know one of
the the bottom 26 000 universities and
the overall student population is about
207 million students but that's going to
be maybe 350 or 380 million students by
2030 so the kind of marginal growth is
like 25 000 students per day
joining the university population
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to a special episode on 20
minute leaders we're talking about
higher education i mean this whole show
is about sort of education but this is
about higher education
and how do we take you know the world we
live in today we take the needs of
students around the world the emerging
needs and how do we have them intersect
into a way that anybody who wants to
acquire higher education has access to
it with accreditation
meet dr joshua brogi the founder and ceo
of wolf a platform that makes it
possible for companies and academic
groups to launch branded degree programs
with the same accreditation as major
universities in weeks not years
he was previously a member of the
faculty of philosophy at oxford and a
member of the governing congregation of
the university he also held a humboldt
fellowship during which he worked the
role of modern universities and support
human progress
joshua brogi welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
well michael it's a real pleasure to be
here thanks for having me on
nah thank you very much for coming here
you're doing such awesome work with
wolfe university coming from higher
education yourself being in the faculty
philosophy within oxford and a variety
of different interesting positions and
now
rethinking a little bit about higher
education and taking into the
entrepreneurial world calling in from a
mountain view the heart of uh you know
tech so tell me a little bit about josh
your own background and your your
passion for higher education what does
that even mean to you how did you get
into this place
yeah uh so i'm from america the new
englander originally been living in the
uk in germany for most the last 10 or 15
years
um i was an academic before uh getting
into tech and so i was on faculty at
oxford and
you know i i started wolf with
colleagues from oxford in 2018.
the goal was to to make world-class
higher education uh more accessible and
available and to ensure the credits were
transferable
my impression working at oxford was that
we could start a new oxford college you
know every couple of months and fill it
with high quality faculty and students
but that would have taken a very long
time and so we ended up
you know deciding to start a new
collegiate university which is kind of
like the university of california system
or the university of london system it's
composed of colleges which are
themselves kind of independently
governed but fall within the
accreditation system so if you go to a
university of california college like
berkeley you get a degree from the
university of california and if you go
to a college at wolf it's independently
managed uh but it falls within the same
quality assurance system and you get a
degree from wolf and has the college
named on it
but i think one of the issues is scale
right so so what it what how what is the
issue of skill within higher education
systems and how you're actually going
about tackling that
yeah it's a great question um you know
globally there are about 27 000
universities in the world um you know
most people have only heard of a small
fraction of them but the majority of
people are are going to you know one of
the the bottom 26 000 universities and
uh the overall student population is
about 207 million students but that's
going to be maybe 350 or 380 million
students by 2030 so the kind of marginal
growth is like 25 000 students per day
uh joining the university population
it's like wow we need to create roughly
three average size universities every
day for the next decade uh just to allow
the service um yeah it's 18 year olds in
in
economies where where the middle class
is really developing they really have
the first chance to go to university so
it's a huge impact
and so
you know tommy tell me a little bit
about wolf university sort of the
intersection of tech higher education
how you're building this out as a sort
of as a startup or as a company how how
does this even work it's even weird
saying startup and and and higher
education in the same sentence
yeah it's a great point so you know
we're the first hired you know
the first
global collegiate university to allow
qualified education organizations to
join us member colleges and issue
accredited degrees so it'd be like if
the university of london went to a boot
camp
or the university of california went to
a small college in south america and
said hey you can join the uc system you
can join the university of london system
as long as you meet our criteria and so
um we are growing by about one new
college every month and we use software
to track all the educational activities
in that college and so the the tech part
of us as a company is
we have a learning platform and an
accreditation management platform
that tracks everything uh related to
quality assurance and compliance for
regulators the kind of end result is we
have three levels as an organization
there are all these colleges where we
have colleges joining us from all over
the world and then we have software
that's tracking their activities then we
have a legal and regulatory layer which
is a set of licenses where we're
actually able to issue degrees that are
recognized by governments so some
college in nigeria does something in our
software which matches a license that we
have and then proof it's an accredited
college offering an accredited degree
and it falls within our system
so it's the first kind of organization
that's like that and allows us to move
really fast without cutting any corners
or or lowering standards
so essentially it sounds like you're
you're you're allowing
already institutions in place that are
already having great faculty great
students except that they and they may
meet the criteria they may need to budge
a little bit to meet the criteria but
you're offering
through software the ability to do sort
of this regulation piece at a higher
paced rate if previously somebody needed
to go travel their back and forth
meetings spend lots of time lots of
paperwork now you're saying we've taken
a lot of this knowledge and pipeline
work we've put it into a software
solution so that we can
you leveraging your data and your
ongoing behavior we can
potentially give you accreditation
types mechanisms within a few weeks
yeah that's right so like the amount of
work that goes into accreditation is
kind of roughly comparable to getting a
banking license and so the idea that
every education organization in the
world needs to get their own unique
license in order to
operate is just a huge lift it really
slows down the process and it's a very
paper-based process and so it's the
reason why you know most education
organizations launch new degree programs
every three to five or eight years and
we're living in a world where the speed
just needs to be a lot higher um you
know software products are you know
launching new new versions every couple
of weeks and so if we live in a world
where we roughly need three new
universities every day um it's it's
millions of dollars three to seven years
in any country to kind of get a
university license then if you want to
launch a new program it's a big process
and so being able to compress those
timelines
is exciting because it means that you
can give students
you know something that's more relevant
and
you can iterate more quickly through
cycles of
education and degree programs without
lowering standards so like ultimately
you know you the reason you have
accreditation is you want to be able to
guarantee assignments that they're
getting a high quality program
is there any pushback from regulators on
this because essentially you're taking
something that is quite sensitive right
i mean there's a lot of pride there
since it and you're essentially saying
we're we're automating pieces of it and
historically anytime you're trying to
automate some
human behavior or some paperwork yeah he
gets a pushback
that's right so you know accreditation
uh is probably not going to go away any
time soon
through pure automation it's it's
embedded in the visa systems and the tax
laws and the migration patterns and the
right to operate in countries all over
the world um
but there is a huge amount of paperwork
that goes into it and so
there are parts of it that software can
automate um and then there are parts of
it where we have a human in the loop so
you might gather a lot of data in real
time and then set up literally a
committee within a university
that has the approval rights about what
to do with that data so it's like did
this program meet all of the
quantifiable standards and metrics yes
or no and you can use software pretty
well for that and then did it meet
certain qualitative factors and then you
send it to the committee and they have
to vote on it in software now that
process would take years normally to
gather all the information on
spreadsheets and email and so on we can
do it in real time so ultimately the
thing that regulators get excited about
when they look at our work is they can
actually get a more granular picture of
what's happening in our organization
than they can in a normal university and
it's kind of 24 7 right so it's not like
an audit every five years you could log
in at any time and see exactly what's
happening down to the level of like
what you know um
assignments are being given to students
and what pdfs are they reading and are
they academic peer-reviewed literature
published in the last five years and all
these kind of very small benchmarks that
typically
are discovered through an audit process
in retrospect uh are happening with us
in real time
take me back to sort of the beginning of
this
um yeah
were you always interested in
scaling higher education and
accessibility was or or is this
something that you sort of stumbled upon
and became excited about
yeah it's a great question um
i i think
being able to to give students access to
just a fantastic educational experience
is something that i'm naturally
passionate about is one of the reasons i
i got into higher education and became a
you know professor a teacher um i i
think you also begin to see the
challenges firsthand so if you're
lecturing in a classroom it's really
common in the united states or the uk
that the students are going into debt
and
you know higher education is expensive
even in countries where students don't
pay very much money for it the taxpayers
are paying for it so it's like germany
where i was also a lecturer um you know
it's uh
300 euros a year to go to university but
the taxpayer is supplementing that with
you know 15 to 30 000 euros per student
um so it's it's a costly uh endeavor i i
think the challenge is when you have
students at one end of the classroom
going into debt and the teacher at the
other end of the classroom not earning
very much and then you wonder where all
the money is disappearing so if there's
a hundred thousand euros worth of
students in the room and the teacher's
getting paid three or four thousand
euros
where's the other 96 going um and you
know it's disappearing into a
bureaucratic machinery where majority of
uh staff at the university are admitting
compliance
you know they're not lecturers they're
they're administrators
and so that's
a system that students are ultimately
paying for and the taxpayers are paying
for
and so i think we can be more efficient
in how we do that and ultimately
students will get a better education for
it
and
for you to get to those realizations
sort of walk me through a little bit
about the ideation process that you've
had you've went through figuring out
okay there is actually you know an
obvious pain point but there's actually
a tangible solution that we can provide
yeah so you know at one point i was
really interested in starting the new
college at oxford and started doing the
legwork on that um when i was on faculty
and i was on the governing parliament to
the university of the congregation and
so started you know laying down the
groundwork for studying new oxford
college and realized okay this is going
to take five or eight years and at the
end of it we're going to have one
college and like really we need like one
college every month um you know not just
like one college over the course of my
career we really need to be able to
expand what we're doing in a new way
given the student numbers in the world
um so i thought it would be possible to
have a much bigger impact
by using software to automate some of
those processes and kind of taking the
cap off of growth
without sacrificing quality
but you know interesting
um
there are a lot of students in the world
who are for the first time um
learning things at the university level
it's it's a very different world that we
live in today than it was say 50 years
ago in terms of student numbers coming
in from developing countries that now
have huge middle classes uh that are
moving into technology and and white
collar jobs for the first time
circling back a little bit to
sort of you know the software here and
the technology that that empowers this
i'd love to get a little bit of a better
sense as to
sort of the technological side of you
know how you're how you're pushing the
boundaries of how we
think through accreditation system or
regulation through software so you
mentioned a little bit through some of
the tracking some of the kpis that
that i guess the regulators have have
seen
what is sort of the technology behind
what you're doing here
yeah it's an interesting question um
there are
two ways that organizations become
accredited first there's something that
happens at the organizational level and
then there's something that happens at
the program level and so both of those
have to be tracked with technology uh
and generally
we are interested in building an
auditable record uh which is kind of
appendally of exactly what's happening
inside an organization as it moves
through a series of processes against
some set of kpis and so at the
organizational level they have to set up
certain committees and they have to form
certain boards and only people with the
right access controls can be members of
those committees so they have to have
their education background verified and
only people with phds can be on certain
committees or only people with master's
degrees could be on other committees and
so all of the people in those profiles
have to get aligned with the different
kind of role-based access control groups
um
at the program level there are a lot
more granular pieces that have to be
tracked related to regulation we don't
get to decide um many of the regulatory
points those get
decided by government partners of ours
and so the government partner might say
it's 25 hours of student labor for every
credit and then we have to find a way to
justify what 25 hours looks like in a
degree program in terms of study and
workload for students and so then the
the job is to say hey uh as a course
creator i'm going to you know designate
this assignment as like a five hour long
assignment or a 25 hour long assignment
or whatever
interesting
so are we transitioning if we're looking
at the you know a little bit down the
line future of higher education is it
you know how how do you think through
about the standardization of higher
education especially you know
con
ideas are changing i'm personally
invested in a few startups that are
looking at at skills-based learning you
know in response to higher education
you obviously you're playing in both of
those worlds how are you seeing higher
education in the future for me i guess a
standardization point of view a
relevancy point of view for for you know
the the extra 25 000 students a day type
of problem
so there are a few different moving
parts one is
um
the old way of measuring things was was
pretty simplistic like how many hours
are you sitting in a chair um
and that's clearly not not a great
measure of whether or not somebody has
learned something and whether or not
they're capable of doing something
and so ultimately you've got to be able
to show that somebody's got a competency
and some delay
but you also need to be able to
communicate across cultural boundaries
and so if somebody calls their kind of
weekend programming course uh masters in
ai um you're probably not at the same
level of like mastery as if you do a
sort of american or european master's
degree which is 2 250 hours exactly
right um and so it's like you go to
stanford you get a master's degree it's
2250 hours that gets expressed as 45
credits you go to europe you do a
master's degree it's 2250 hours it's
expressed as 90 credits um and so you
need some like translation in between
systems to be able to know the
difference between 45 american credits
and 90 european credits but at the same
time like just sitting in a chair for
2000 hours is not going to make you
really good at managing artificial
intelligence so getting the balance
there i think is really important um
you know increasingly
skills matter a lot but what we
typically see is with organizations that
come to us if they've asked a student to
study for a year or two years in their
boot camp like
it gets really hard to express that to
an employer if you don't have a master's
degree and if you're explaining you're
kind of losing and so it's like no i
promise this program was was really more
substantive than other programs where
there's just like no explanation to do
if you can just say oh i have a european
master's degree that i receive from this
and then people understand what it is
and you know the employer
has a shorthand way of understanding
exactly what happened
interesting
very very interesting and so the vision
here with wolf university
you know or where do you see this you
know long term obviously in short term
you know you're growing you're scaling
well where is what is sort of the goal
or the win of wolfe university yeah
so i i think we're building the largest
collegiate university in the world
and you know right now it's it's a
relatively simple thing where people
plug into our software and they're able
to prove to our regulatory partners that
they meet all the quality assurance
standards set up by those government
officials and so you effectively plug in
and very rapidly um
are able to demonstrate that you meet
and maintain compliance for
accreditation and so plug in get
accredited um
but we're layering in more of the back
office services that you would find in a
large university when it comes to
research resources and things like that
and so as we scale the number of
colleges across our system
students get access to more scholarships
and more financing options they get
access to
interesting benefits that come from
other colleges and we really want to get
to a place where you can kind of go to
any city in the world and there are
multiple wolf colleges
that are there
and that's a really exciting prospect
that we were recently in mexico city and
i think there were two wolf colleges and
a third wolf college getting started um
and you know there are opportunities for
meetups and and new kind of social
dynamics uh from the community that
emerged from that
interesting and so do do you see
yourself staying in the realm of sort of
providing that extra layer of
accreditation or that the the
standardization for for these colleges
or users of also getting involved with
the actual education system and and
different engagements with students or
networks marketplaces
etc yeah so um
i'd like to think that that
accreditation would just kind of go away
and that what you'd really end up with
is proof around skills or something like
that i i don't think that will happen i
think it's way too deeply embedded in
the way governments work um but i think
we have the the proof around student
skills and that's a huge unlock for
employment partners and so for us to be
able to then partner with employers and
being able to say hey look this is a
really good student that can match your
needs i think that's quite exciting um
i i think
we won't teach at wolf so our colleges
teach and you know it's like the
university of california doesn't teach
anything berkeley teaches something and
ucla teaches something and so like the
colleges provide the teaching or
university of london that doesn't have
faculty
casey london has faculty um and in
virtue of being in kcl you're you're
faculty of the whole university um so
like we won't teach we won't have
students we won't have faculty but we
can provide white label course content
uh you know really high quality kind of
libraries of books and videos and things
like that to our colleges and so we can
kind of improve their resources um
but i i don't think that we'll end up
teaching i don't think we'll be able to
totally overcome uh government
restrictions but we can reduce the
friction so we've built like the only
credit exchange system between borders
uh that i that i know of at least and so
you can easily stack credits across our
system uh natively
that's very very cool i i love the way
that you're that you know you're coming
from the system you're identifying the
pain point you're understanding
technology in the and coming in with
fresh eyes and understanding that you
can
sort of create to this
reduce that friction you know be in
between borders and
and and it's a you know from somebody
from the outside it sounds like such a
complicated world that's so regulated
and so heavy yet that you're coming and
you're actually doing it you're building
you know the world's largest uh i guess
standardized accreditation system called
allowing colleges to participate in it
and and at the end creating a very
positive impact on students um and
that's obviously the the end goal here
so joshua thank you so much for coming
here and sharing with me uh 20 minutes
is not nearly enough to for for me to to
understand everything that you're doing
but but it is enough for me to to want
to dive into it myself and to to get
inspired by it so thank you and best of
luck with wolf university and stay safe
and stay healthy
many thanks michael it's a real pleasure
thanks for having me on really
appreciate it
thank you bye josh
you